As we wrap up, I want to welcome
you one more time to CS6460,
Educational Technology.
We'll be running most of the class
through announcements and
through interactions on the forum, so
I'd recommend you check those often.
And in fact, I'd really recommend
you check in at least once per day,
if only for a few minutes.
Part of the goal for this course is to
develop a community of collaborators,
and communities really
thrive on frequent activity.
You'll definitely see us there and
we hope to see you there as well.
Beyond that, we're really excited
to see what you come up with, and
we're looking forward
to getting started.
I hope you are, too.